our vowel smear cough ski and Jenna  Johnson rekindling their romance let's  see what happened Val and Jenna are  showing signs that they might be dating  again both stars posted similar pigs to  Instagram from a joint trip to Rome are  we going  Jenna appeared to be in good spirits  smiling from ear to ear while touring  Italy while Val really teased us with  this sweet shot a shadow of two  unidentified people kissing I can't  control what people think I live my life  and note the bracelet on the mystery man  holding Jenna's hand in this [ __ ] it's  the same one bowing in this snap  indulging in some Italian ice cream the  two have yet to publicly address whether  they are back together but we think the  dancing duo are a match made in heaven  [Music]